but there is one individual that i would
like to i'd like to ask you about in
terms of the conversation uh james
o'keefe because if this one person i
think is
you know the real deal in terms of
sticking his neck out and you know uh
jumping into the fray the tip of the
spear as it were as he james o'keefe is
fighting the fight and more so than most
people he's for real yeah he's legit and
he's doing a lot of great work and he's
winning a lot of important battles but
if you go to his wikipedia page
you'll notice that it is the most insane
garbled propaganda it is if
what's uh what's the word for defamation
but like 100 orders of magnitude larger
that's what it is and it's amazing
because the wikipedia page for james
o'keefe is very clearly an op-ed it is
not in any way fact based now my
question is how does wikipedia get away
with smearing james o'keefe the way they
they do and i'll i'll elaborate on this
we've talked about it before uh they say
project well not necessarily games will
keep specifically they do smear but
project veritas they say it's far right
it's an activist group they produce
deceptive video edits you know secret
recordings
entrapment um generating bad publicity
it's propagate propagating
disinformation conspiracy theories now
all of these
are this this page from wikipedia
the citations are opinion pieces
wikipedia doesn't say it's the the free
opinion aggregator it says it's the free
encyclopedia which is a natural
definition what encyclopedia is
so i'm sure there's some kind of
argument they can make well look
someone's opinion it you know somebody
chooses to cite it as an you know as a
fact in here that's not us
here's here's the question i have work
it's interesting
if i post a tweet saying james o'keefe
once uh ate a whole pizza by himself
a large pepperoni uh and it's not true i
have defamed him i have libeled him
right and
only if that's
something that would constitute i mean
well that might be a positive statement
depending sure let's say i said james
o'keefe did bad thing and it results in
him losing tons of money and donors
and it's not true so he says here's the
damages you've defamed me you've libeled
me and i'm suing you for damages yeah
twitter says don't look at us that says
tim poole checkmark and the tweet
clearly came from him section 230 not on
us right it would be on me personally
if it's your tweet correct right well
when i pull up project veritas on
wikipedia it says
from wikipedia
project veritas from wikipedia the free
encyclopedia the name attached to this
post is wikipedia not john smith or bill
hammond or
edgar allen poe literally wikipedia
i can understand the argument that when
someone posts something in their names
next to it it's their statement but what
wikipedia is doing
is displaying no names
if i want to figure out who added one
section to this i might have to dig
through
hundreds of pages no because wikipedia
has already decided
that we have taken other people's
comments and crafted it into an article
we put our name on
at what point is this wikipedia speech
especially when they say it's from them
tim you've given me much to unpack here
but we have time
first
before i say anything else i have to say
that we also represent james o'keefe and
project veritas ah right on
and
we have two pending lawsuits that we
filed in the last month or so
which were
which earned me ice cream
and my followers will understand that
that's how i reward myself and i've done
a great job
um
that's number one so
there's on the one hand i will
have to limit my
comments on the other hand are you i'm
also telling you that i'm biased but no
more i'm no more biased than i was
before because like you
you look at james o'keefe and you know
he's there he's absolutely the real deal
let's not even uh i just pull up project
veritas simply because it's very obvious
definition but let's say
literally anything else let's say uh uh
you know my pillow so i'm not sure that
that section 230 covers wikipedia at all
i don't think it's an internet service
provider i don't know if that's been
tested but as you said whom do you sue
the problem there is corporate
accountability let me just point out
though
that
the reason we care i i think it is
there's that there's a consensus
in the political and policy and
internet part that we occupy
that wikipedia is garbage
unless you're looking up species of
butterflies
and you know the most generic stuff but
anything
juicy anything
it's known at this point to be
garbage
but here's the problem
google considers it a highly
authoritative right resource
that's why we have to break up google
because google which is not an internet
service provider as such
search engine
google editorializes and manipulates
results
for political purposes and it has a
right to do just like people also know
that google's garbage
but you know what
i don't want to say the name
of the alternative search engine that i
use because i don't want to hurt i don't
want to hurt their business
but
so if i want to look up species of
butterflies it's fine
but if i really need to get information
i'm inevitably going to end up back at
google and having to use my
super brain to get past
the bias because
these guys their search engines not as
good it's not as good you know bing's a
little bit better
actually
but
it's not with the wikipedia part it's
the way it and this is not this is this
is an aspect of network effects
it's the way that that wikipedia has
been baked into google and so is twitter
and there's been extremely little
attention paid to the partnership
between google and twitter
i i see what you're saying about
wikipedia if you google search someone's
name there's a box that appears and has
wikipedia information which could be
completely made up and there's been very
funny stories about
people having their wikipedias changed
by random users and then it appears on
google which then transfers to your you
know amazon or google device so you're
at home and then you'll ask your little
computer who was you know george
washington he was a pancake salesman
because somebody edited wikipedia the
system's fairly fractured if you ask me
but
i think the attack vector in terms of
challenging
this malfeasance is
sure you could argue breaking up google
but
sue wikipedia uh yeah i mean so as ions
knows they desperately need your
donations they won't shut up about it i
i'm sure
it's been tried i know that i've seen
the case captions i think the issue with
wikipedia is
i think they might actually the the
corporate home of wikipedia is somewhere
that's not
in this country
it's in some
country that isn't going to work out too
well for litigation something like that
and and also one that probably is not as
amenable
to
um disclosure as the united states it's
not well it's ukraine but you know it's
so let's think about the the the problem
we're facing there this is something
that i've had a lot of concerns about
going into the 2020 election twitter
will ban a conservative for saying their
opinion an american citizen with a
political opinion on twitter will get
banned but an australian citizen who has
a contradictory opinion that supports
the left will be allowed to get all the
retreats in the world so you actually
have foreign influence so long as it
supports the agenda of one faction
gaining traction and being protected
while american citizens i'll tell you
this laura loomer might be considered by
many to be distasteful or they don't
like her they think she's bombastic or
just they really don't like her because
oh you know because she's high energy
we'll call her that but she's an
extremely enthusiastic young lady yes
she's an american citizen who has a
right to speak and be engaged in
politics whether you like it or not but
she's removed from every platform
meanwhile i see it on reddit every day
someone will comment on american news
there's a little australian new zealand
flag a canadian flag a russian flag why
do these people get to influence and be
involved in our conversation but our own
american citizens aren't allowed i'll do
you one better
first i'll say that laura loom is also
my client
oh my well good good right on and one of
the things
that we tried to argue and the judges
simply
they use section 230 to just get rid of
any we don't think they're going to be
able to do this with the handling case
with the dc drainage case because of the
government action it's just too over the
top but
in laura's case
our argument essentially was
you know the first amendment prohibits
the government from censoring
speech of citizens
but only the u.s government
what if care let's just say the council
on american
arab america what is it
council on american islamic relations
let's just say they accepted money from
a foreign government
a nasty foreign government
and that foreign government
told care
here's what you need to do here are the
voices you need to silence in order for
us to more effectively message on this
issue
and
qatar just for example
therefore decides that laura loomer
should be censored the first amendment
has nothing to say about that
twitter takes orders
from we know twitter takes orders i
don't know about twitter we know that
there's an issue with
with platforms and and and technology
companies taking orders from china yeah
also from europe from european
governments that have restrict anti-hate
laws right well
what we're really talking about here is
the fact that
the
the technology companies
are themselves not beholden to any
particular government they are bigger
than
sovereign states they are more powerful
and wealthier than most sovereign states
in the world
and
libertarians say
build your own twitter
dude
they are already
the emperors well it's actually you've
it's really simple then uh i think by
outlining this problem all we got to do
is
ask our politicians to regulate these
companies to prevent the foreign
interference now i know the democrats
probably greatly benefit from that
interference but i'm sure they'll see
reason
right well i'll tell you something on
the culmination podcast
i actually interviewed
representative ken buck last week
who has introduced a bill to do just
that and it's a bipartisan bill hey
that's great it's a bipartisan bill and
it's it is more oriented towards
anti-trust enforcement then to
censorship per se
but as we have just demonstrated
they're intimately related
because
if you
have the only platform that matters
doesn't matter
whether i've got an alternative it's an
ultra i'm like yeah i can go into the
room with all the bean bags in it
downstairs to scream my head off so i
have freedom of speech but no one's
going to hear me
so after i after i i get you canceled
because of this you know episode of
tim in real life
that's gonna be the same thing for you
imagine if uh before the age of the
internet
fox news kept putting vladimir putin on
prime time to talk about how americans
should vote and people listened and they
voted the way he said i mean that would
be
insane you know we we couldn't imagine
something like that happening then we
get four or five years of them screaming
that donald trump was
the benefactor of just that
while quite literally there are foreign
governments
influencing through social media either
investing in companies and getting some
say in them or actually just being
extremely wealthy foreign
high-ranking officials put it that way
political figures making demands and
promising favors and it happens our
political system is corrupted if that's
the case and i don't see why you know
even if
you know ken buck does propose this
legislation
i'm not confident for one that democrats
would want to give up the freebies
they're getting and the republicans are
too stupid to do anything about it so
there are a couple of things going on i
asked him why are democrats in on this
and i think he acknowledged
their concerns are not the same concerns
as ours
but
there is
to some extent i think he agreed with my
suggestion that now that trump is
gone
whatever that really means i mean i
think we all understand that he is
running the country from a nuclear
submarine off the coast
um although many people who are banned
from twitter would probably wish
fortunately he's not
um
although i will i will tell you if you
ask alexa
don't turn on please i just yelled at me
alexa stopped
apparently
apparently i shouldn't say the name ever
again uh apparently it says that trump
is the president
and and like people are laughing and
hooting like this it's always amazon
says it it's like okay dude it's a
stupid computer program
so
i must admit that even i lost even i
lost the thread there um
sorry about that no that's okay anything
for a good gag especially when you're
gonna get you're talking about uh asking
the democrats why they were in on it
so there i i think
the world
is a little bit safer for democrats to
actually be democrats when they don't
have to merely oppose something because
it benefits donald trump
i'm not still sure why there's some why
there seems i mean biden
appointed as head of the federal trade
commission so
everybody understands right there are
two agencies in the u.s government that
are mainly in charge of anti-trust
enforcement one is the anti-trust
division of the justice department
which is a relatively more political
agency compared to the federal trade
commission which focuses more on
mergers and acquisitions but which is
also involved in
an industry consul industry shares and
domination
um because that's obviously part and
parcel of of acquisitions
that's traditionally considered
considered to be a less political agency
biden
appointed and she was approved
as fgc commissioner
a woman who has a reputation as being a
critic of big tech
now
those of us such as myself who have been
saying for six months that
joe biden is
what is called in
hebrew a golem
meaning like basically a
zombie
a puppet
incapable of independent thought he's
just you know weakened to bernie's kind
of situation
it's hard for me not to believe that
that he is in which case for some reason
the powers that be either want to do
this incredibly elaborate false flag
operation like at some point you have to
start believing that maybe things may
appear to be what they are or maybe
there is still a constituency within the
democrat party and by the way i'm not so
sure that
the squad isn't part of that
constituency
that doesn't like big business
and sees these global corporations
because remember to to to a real
progressive a preposterous term
to a real leftist
the state has to have all the power
even if you tell me well but no but
google and all these technology
companies have been integrated into this
state they're all the same
not so fast
they want to be able to press a button
as
officer so
well this is the best they're going to
get i mean the government can't
literally censor but they can do this
highly circuitous method which you know
you're now suing over right so so if
that's the case if there actually might
be some sort of
bipartisan so what we see though is that
so today
there was a tweet from
from congressman jordan jim jordan
saying why would i want to give
joe biden's regulators more power over
over business
answer
what else you got jim
what else have you got
trump certainly wasn't getting anything
done george
w bush got nothing republican this idea
that republicans should reflexively be
the friends of big business as a joke we
see where big business has been on the
blm
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you